And now for the answer.
Well, we can find this out by ourselves simply by running this in the IDE.
Here is our input: I click on Run
and you can see that the binary search simplification
does not simplify as much as one could imagine.
In the beginning we had this 20-character string,
which would then be reduced to this 10-character string
just by splitting this in half
and now if we split this again into two 5-character strings,
none of the two halves will actually contain a select tag.
So both will pass,
and therefore we'll stick with the original string,
which in this case simply then is followed by "fo."
So, for the quiz, 'fo' is the correct answer.